[Musique]
c'est l'heure de se la péter ou de la
boucler
[Musique]
au fait
c'est l'heure de se la péter ou de la
boucler
bienvenue à zombieland vivre c'est pas
simplement survivre
on était une famille dysfonctionnelle je
vous mets quelle famille ne l'est pas je
ne fais pas ce geste les septs avoir
dans ce fauteuil je pense que j'aurais
été un sacré bon président c'est vrai
qu'on peut compter sur toi pour sublimer
la fonction au ps je suis désolé je
m'appelle columbus une à nice m mais
c'est à la c
pouvoir ouais
vieux monsieur est tout petit il n'est
plus là il est là il l'est plus et il
l'est voici la petite fille est adorable
ma soeur a disparu jal est parti avec un
mec un gars de berkeley dit aurait pas
de l'herbe sur toi tant parce que j'ai
la tête d'un mec qui aurait de l'herbe
je suis vraiment désolé surprise voilà
récupérer on décolle à l'aube
[Musique]
traduit en dix ans
m
bon